[Music]
evening everyone and welcome to the next
revolution I'm Steve Hilton and this is
the home of positive populism pro-worker
pro-family pro-communist a one thing at
the beginning I want to say a huge thank
you to all of you who got behind our Joe
China campaign last week on swamp watch
that's really important
we've got more on that coming up later
tonight but I really want to say thanks
to all of you who got that going all
right but I want to start the show
tonight with this Sarah Sanders asking
reporters to turn the page as it relates
to the Muller report I have to remind
you don't turn the page turn back look
at the page
what did Democrats need to do to keep
the focus on the Muller report that's it
right there what do they need to do to
keep the focus on Russia they don't want
to talk about the economy because it's
booming they don't want to talk about
their policies because they're
increasingly loony they just want to
talk about Russia and divide America in
the process remember that as you hear
them endlessly pompously pontificating
about threats to our democracy it is all
just a political tactic to keep the
focus on Russia and tonight I want to
prove that to you
forensically in detail with facts and
their own words
watch closely let's first examine the
argument the establishment uses as a
serious justification for all this the
national security requirement to stand
up to Russia and its behavior here's an
old friend talking about just that last
week you're in the Kremlin you're
Vladimir Putin who I've sat across I
understand his goal is to weaken America
I know that he doesn't like me because I
stood up for America are you thinking
what I'm thinking okay play the tape I
wanted to present you with a little gift
which represents what President Obama
and Vice President Biden and I have
saying and that is we want to reset our
relationship actually we found a better
one and this is something she said on
Russian TV perhaps she hoped we wouldn't
find it but we did quote we want very
much to have a strong Russia because a
strong confident prosperous stable
Russia is we think in the interest of
the world yeah you stick it to Putin
Hillary of course it wasn't just her he
is President Obama and why he was soft
on Putin over Ukraine quote the fact is
that Ukraine which is a non NATO country
is going to be vulnerable to military
domination by Russia no matter what we
do now the establishment are frothing at
the mouth of a President Trump not
raising 2016 election meddling with
Putin on their call this Friday hang on
a second didn't the meddling happen
under Obama who was told about it at the
time What did he say to Putin he told
him to cut it out I bet Putin was
quaking in his boots after that
especially after Obama told the whole
world that dictators could get away with
anything on his watch after he let Syria
flout his red lines on chemical weapons
by contrast it's Trump who put tough
sanctions on Russia who expelled
diplomats who arm the Ukrainians and
above all who totally changed America's
energy policy in a way that Russia hates
oh and who was it who launched an actual
cyber attack on Russia over election
meddling no not the Craven Obama but
Donald Trump I think that's a little
tougher than cut it out Vladimir so
let's get real none of this is about
substance or national security or even
election meddling it is pure politics
remember that tomorrow we're hours away
from the deadline Jerry Nadler has set
for the release of Congress of the
unredacted Mullah report the Attorney
General we got a letter late last night
refusing us refusing to adhere to the
subpoena this is indefensible and it is
part of the attack on American democracy
by this administration
he wants the unredacted report he must
have the unredacted report democracy
depends on it
but he's already got it Nadler you total
charlatan there was a report available
to you without three of the four types
of redaction in the public version you
didn't even bother to go and look at it
last week you just had to walk down the
street to the Department of Justice
headquarters it takes 20 minutes
according to Google Maps this week it
moved right to Capitol Hill it's
literally in your building the Millar
report without three out of four types
of reaction removing the fourth is
literally against the law but you're the
one going on about defending democracy
this fuss is all because the Millar
report didn't give the establishment
what they wanted so now they're trying
to keep the Russian nonsence going by
saying the whole thing is a cover-up by
an attorney general who were somewhat
unhinged and Nancy Pelosi called a liar
he lied to Congress and everybody else
did that it would be considered a crime
nobody is above the law not the
President of the United States and not
the Attorney General all right so this
is the moment he's supposedly lied
reports have emerged recently general
that members of the special counsels
team are frustrated at some level with
the limited information included in your
March 24th letter that it does not
adequately or accurately necessarily
portray the report's findings do you
know what they're referencing with that
no I do so when you cut it right there
it does sound like he lied when he said
that the Attorney General had Robert
Miller's letter asking for his summary
to be put out but that wasn't the
hospital answer here's the rest I
suspect that they probably wanted you
know more put out but in my view I was
not interested in putting out summaries
or trying to summarize he literally
described the substance of Miller's
complaint so it was a bar who lied
Nanci as usual they are projecting
accusing others of the berry thing that
they do all the time just look at this
you know if the bureau ever relied on
the Steele dossier as any as part of any
court filings applications petitions
pleadings I have no awareness did the
CIA rely on it no one I because we we
did it wasn't part of the corpus of
intelligence information that we had it
was not in any way used as a basis for
the Intel community assessment that was
done why isn't Nancy calling for Brennan
to be prosecuted for lying to Congress
because they're all on the same team the
establishment team tried to keep the
focus on Russia another tactic is
pretending this was never really about
collusion the most laughable example
came during the coverage of last week's
bar hearing when NBC's Brian Williams
cut in with this important announcement
that a phrase or the lack of it its
absence from federal code this no
collusion mantra is so foundational to
why we're here today that we decided to
flag it when we heard him use it yet
again yep that phrase collusion not a
thing not at all it's not about
collusion right Brian
collusion collusion collusion collusion
collusion illusion collusion collusion
for the record the president has said
collusion on Twitter ninety four times
nearly as much as you but perhaps the
most deranged claim from the
establishment is that William Parr is
running a cover-up this is Robert Miller
saying hey Attorney General fire stop
lying about my report and it gives us a
ton of new information about how hard
Muller has been fighting to try to get
his report out and how many times and
how many ways bar has been blocking that
from happening bar covering up molars
findings and misrepresenting molars
findings and refusing to release molars
actual findings exposing molars personal
fight against the Trump administration
to try to undo
the cover-up of his investigation and
his findings
okay so publishing something is now
covering it up you know I think we need
to demand that MSNBC boss Phil Griffin
stops covering up Rachel Maddow's and
monologues America needs to hear what
she has to say every weeknight at 9:00
p.m.
democracy depends on it there's Rachel
just trying to get her opinion out and
how many times and how many ways that
evil Phil Griffin has been blocking that
from happening
covering up Rachel Maddow's monologues
maybe he's secretly working there Sean
Hannity or they're Russians but even on
its own crazy logic the cover-up theory
makes no sense according to the deranged
establishment the cover-up was revealed
by Miller's complaint letter the bit
they point to is this the summary letter
the department sent to Congress and
released to the public late in the
afternoon of March the 24th did not
fully capture the context nature and
substance of this offers his work and
conclusions okay
so let's talk about the substance the
aim of Muller was to investigate Russian
interference in any coordination by the
Trump campaign plus obstruction that's
exactly what Barr addressed in his
original letter no indictment on any of
it
that is the substance it's just that the
establishment doesn't like it Miller's
letter complained about public confusion
and misunderstanding and you can see why
the public were confused for years
they'd been told Trump was a Russian
agent but Muller said he wasn't after
the Attorney General announced that fact
Miller wanted to put more out there but
that wouldn't have changed the substance
it just would have changed the spin now
why the hell does Miller care about any
of that the public understanding the
media coverage the spin the
establishment love describing attorney
general Barr as Trump's lawyer well by
his own letter Robert Miller told us how
he sees himself he is the establishments
spin doctor many in the media say oh how
can you question Miller he's a
Republican that misses the whole point
the big divide here is not between
Republicans in
Democrats but between the establishment
and populism between insiders and
outsiders Muller is the ultimate insider
as we told you in a swamp watch a few
months ago Robert Miller Swamp penis
goes beyond awarding billion dollar
contracts to his best friend's employer
after leaving his post as FBI director
what did this modern-day Saint this
paragon of ethics and integrity do he
cashed in of course Lula
went back to work for his old law and
lobbying firm now called Wilma Hale and
surprise surprise his clients were
directly related to his previous
government work one of them was Booz
Allen Hamilton like Lockheed Martin a
giant surveillance contractor Bloomberg
has called them the world's most
profitable spy agency this whole Russia
mania is about the establishment
fighting back and there's no better
example of that than Nicole Wallace an
attorney general who turns out to be
Donald chunk of the brain what do you
make of just a complete departure from
reality but the Republicans have gone to
Al and only familiar to die-hard viewers
of Fox News primetime yes the chunk
should get the blame but it would seem
that when the people around him become
polluted by his lack of any sort of
character that there's reason to to
worry just as much about those people
Barr is saying I mean it's sort of like
watching The Princess Bride like up is
down and down is up and purples green
and blue is red and the floors the
ceiling and the ceiling is floor Oh what
was that today good question
Nicole Wallace and the rest of her
establishment crony should ask it of
themselves they lie about the Attorney
General being a liar they accused Trump
of being Putin's puppet when they're the
ones helping Putin divide America they
condemn talk of deep state spying as a
smear even though there's plenty of
evidence for it while they spent the
last two years smearing the president as
a Russian agent with absolutely no
evidence at all they are the ones these
establishment sycophants who scream
about Trump undermining democracy in the
rule of law well it's all then it's you
Nicole Wallace it's you Chuck Todd it's
you Jerry Nadler it's you Adam Schiff
and yes you the ridiculous Erick's wall
well refusing to accept an election and
using every trick in the book to
overturn its result that's what this is
about all of it an arrogant and entitled
ruling class that cannot believe that
peasants have taken power away from them
well long may that revolution continue